a man is facing hate charges after an  attack on a local asian business owner  happened friday night near flamingo and  buffalo police say 36 year old anthony  deshari yelled anti-asian slurs at  restaurant employees then came back  later and attacked the owner metro  police and other community leaders came  together today reminding everyone of the  importance of reporting these types of  incidents  we the police department cannot do this  by ourselves  we have to have you the community  involved  you have to be our eyes you have to be  our ears  if you see something you have to say it  you have to report it no matter how  small that crime might seem  the eight news now i-team has reported  on the lack of reporting when a hate  crime happens metro police say of the  dozens of incidents the department  investigated in 2020 and 2021 just two  were anti-asian related denise